we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P so many of you calling
in about the Trump town hall on CNN most
of you were appalled let's listen to a
couple of these voicemails
yeah hi David uh I just have to say
about this Trump thing tonight on CNN
I'm about 38 minutes into it and um
pause walk outside and de-stress every
10 minutes or so but
thing that CNN did here is the crowd
the crowd is full of sickness right it's
like a last track absolutely I mean you
have Caitlin Collins who I honestly you
know I looked at this tonight and I
heard your you know I listened to your
live stream and I heard you're so
earlier today and I'm thinking of myself
the biggest persons you know that's got
everything on the line it's not Trump
it's Kate and Collins
and she's trying to interview this man
where the crowd is literally a laugh
track from the 1960s I don't
understand why CNN put their own
employee in this position but yeah so
this is this is part of the argument I
made about Caitlyn Collins you know
there is praise and criticism of Caitlin
Collins but putting her in that position
with a sycophant crowd is part of the
friendly nature in in total with which
Trump was given this opportunity uh
let's listen to another caller about the
uh Trump Town Hall I think this is the
Eggman
I watched Trump and Caitlyn Collins on
CNN last night like it was a homework
assignment yeah I watched it like I had
to do it because it was something I
needed to report on my wife was watching
with me she walked out of the room it
upset her so much you can't stand Trump
that much you couldn't even listen
anymore but I forced myself to watch I
can't wait to hear what you have to say
yeah
um the Eggman quite appalled by it and
here's one more caller wangan
hi yeah Dave um
semi-longtime listener about maybe less
than a year um
I've watched the Trump or listen to the
Trump town hall and it was pretty within
five minutes of listening I was just
like this is a waste of time I mean I
get why CNN did it I mean
but
we didn't learn anything about problems
that we didn't already know that's true
but we learned a lot about the state of
trump sycophants because when you look
at when the crowd laughed and when the
crowd cheered it was at the absolute
bottom of the barrel moments when Trump
attacked his own sexual assault victim
during the event the crowd laughed and
cheered when Trump attacked the
moderator uh Caitlyn Collins the crowd
laughed and cheered when Trump said he
actually won in 2020 the crowd cheered
the crowd was actually what was new
Trump did his Greatest Hits and it was
truly truly horrible we've got a great
bonus show for for you today we'll talk
about the latest out of the Supreme
Court we're going to talk about Fox News
hit with yet another defamation lawsuit
and we will also talk about uh Senator
representing California Dianne
Feinstein's return to the senate for the
first time since February amid calls for
her to resign we'll discuss the entire
circumstances around her return all on
the bonus show thank your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave Pacman you
don't have to be me to listen to the
bonus show or to watch it I'll host it
you watch it sign up at joinpakman.com
otherwise we'll be back tomorrow with a
brand new show